[Music]
is a dangerous one and attacks are
plenty and constant
the journey is pitted with risks as the
russians try to cut off the only route
and all those using it to come into the
city
it's the one remaining pocket of
ukrainian resistance in the war zone
which is lehansk the smaller of the two
areas making up the donbass region and
which the russians appear set on seizing
it's absolutely littered with vehicles
the route is scattered with the evidence
of russian aggression their failures
elsewhere has made victory here more
crucial and the russians have all but
taken lehansk bombing it relentlessly
now several donetsk is the key city
standing in the way of the invaders
moving into the second half of donbass
and donetsk
there are an estimated few thousand
civilians still here
despite the relentless shelling the
chief of police and his team are trying
to persuade them to leave and are here
to evacuate those who will agree to go
but many won't they've elderly family to
care for
but saying goodbye is horribly hard
they've no idea if they'll ever see each
other again
this war has broken hearts and torn so
many families apart and each one is a
personal tragedy
there's no electricity no running water
no phone or internet connection here
anymore without them cooking for their
sick and elderly relatives they die
alone
but there are considerable risks
[Music]
do you feel that the russians are
getting closer
[Music]
the ukrainians have tried to slow the
russians progress by blowing up the last
railway bridge connecting the now
russian-held territory with sevra
donetsk
but the explosion may only be a
temporary setback and giving up any land
in the donbass is inconceivable
you will be fight for your home for your
family
you cannot understand
why you must
give your home
so you'll never give up i think now
the city's last working hospital has
been bombed continuously for the past
few weeks
and the hospital buildings are still
coming under attack relentlessly and
there are still about 40 patients being
treated here
targeting civilians and hospitals and
medical staff is a war crime under
international law
situations in hospital change every day
and if we coming
two days ago one situation and after
shooting situations in change
not every day
every hour
many of the patients are in beds along
the corridor walls to shield them from
blasts looked after by a single doctor
leading a small team of medics
what would happen if you went
uh
yeah
they moved around the hospital
continually to dodge the attacks which
don't let up
there's unexploded ordnance outside
and a whistle indicating the russians
are firing more
let's remember they're attacking a
hospital with patients
they're still shelling this area so
everyone's leaving of course the
patients have to stay behind
the ukrainians are going to have to
mount a fierce counter-offensive if
they're to hold back the russians alex
crawford sky news in several donetsk in
eastern ukraine